Hello Freak bitches.
The,
I mean people ask me like why would they want to be on TV?
Cause everybody wants to be on TV.
Like we talked to a bunch of different clan groups and are they,
the producers did,
most of them didn't want to be on TV but there was like three or four that did
cause they,
they thought they were spreading the word.
Maybe they were,
you know,
what was their message like when you were talking to them?
Like what,
what was the reason for them doing this?
They believe America is a white country ordained by God.
That way they believe the Bible says that's true.
They believe the Bible talks about a man.
That's what I'm saying.
It's like,
I'm not telling you what I believe,
but they believed that the Bible doesn't think that the racist should mix.
The Bible doesn't,
you know,
all these things that people quite at the Bible,
the Bible is talking about donkeys and they were like,
you know,
so the data and they believe that America is a white country founded by white
people and that,
that the,
that the people who like the black people in the Mexican people and eventually
the Catholics and the Jews only they can say a cooler with Catholics.
Now these days the Catholics should get to leave,
go back home.
And because America is a,
and the,
and the whole America is for white people is the whole white is just a different
way of saying the white ethno state thing that a lot of the people or the alt
right and the national,
the white nationalist movement say then,
so you know,
they,
they think that this is,
that they,
they think America's,
they think this,
the whole idea of America is that it's for whites only and that the rest of us
need to go home.
I feel for you.
I mean I'd be standing there with these people in the woods in Kentucky looking
into the eyes of madness,
whether we're in satin sheets over their head with holes poked out for eyes.
Well it's sort of,
there was a lot of it that was fun.
I mean it was like we got there,
I got out of the car and there's a line in the,
in the show where you can hear me before you see that I'm going like,
oh this wasn't a good idea.
And that was really me saying this was not a good idea.
That was not me making a joke cause I see a phalanx of them and they're all
standing there at attention.
And right when we got there,
the guy who was an all blue was like immediately goes into a rant about
Ferguson.
It was in 2014 so it was all about Ferguson and how black people aren't policed
themselves and do the white man is going to Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
While at the same time they don't advocate violence cause it's clear that at
some point they were told if you talk about violence the FBI will be here every
weekend.
You know,
so they're like,
we don't advocate violence.
We advocate self defense.
We don't hate black people,
we just love our people but also black people can't look what they're doing in
Ferguson that shows that black people aren't whatever blah blah blah are the
equivalent of the white man.
And uh,
and so I had to,
so when we first started shooting,
I,
there was this like this guy was just gone off and I just heard it was like
having to take it and wondering is this going to be the next three hours?
It's this kind of just like yelling.
And the producer stepped in and said,
all right everybody,
let's just,
oh we got to check the camera for a second.
And we slowed it down and then we set up chairs when we sat down and started
talking and it from that point forward,
they were so excited to talk about their clan thing cause they don't get asked
that a lot.
That they sort of like eventually you would if you weren't thinking that it was
the Klan,
you'd be like,
yeah,
it's just people talking about their lives.
I don't agree with them,
but they're,
they're not,
they didn't stay angry.
I was talking to this photographer,
I was at this festival this weekend and she had a,
uh,
a film camera you don't like,
do you develop your own Phipps?
She's,
oh no,
you can always develop black and white because if you develop,
you know,
color pictures,
the fumes,
well they'll knock you right out.
And so I said,
so just a little bit of that would be a great time.
It's a small,
so just get a little bit of that and you can just huffing paint.
Yeah,
you could do a Goddamn job interview.
Naylin maybe just a little bit us just like crack a vial in front of Mike,
grow dose of a little bit of that.
Have you ever tried poppers?
Poppers are,
those are the things that they crack them and they sniff it.
Emile nitrate or thing it's called no,
I did whip us in college.
Oh yeah,
I did that when I worked at a creamery.
I worked at Newport creamery.
It was like a ice cream place and they had a,
the ice cream.
Those a big vats that,
what is the gas?
Nitrous oxide oxide,
right.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
And we would,
uh,
we would do
like socks off of it.
That killed a lot of brands.
That kills a lot of brands.
I remember I did one weekend in college and then I think I did it on a Friday
night and on the Sunday I was just walking around yelling all weird.
I don't know if I was forced into Yale just because I was trying to justify it
how I felt or if it was a natural yell,
but yelling was happening.
Wow.
Yeah.
And you couldn't help it.
I don't know.
You know,
sometimes you ever just tweak out by yourself just to,
you haven't you?
Never just,
you absolutely do.
After like a crazy workout.
Hi ma'am.
Yeah,
I have to work.
I'm usually spent week out just of Connor at the way in was just tweaking out,
but it was for show which was shelf.
Sometimes you put a show for yourself,
change your state of mind just by yourself.
Yeah.
Like people say,
if you smile,
change your mind.
Right.
It will change the way your brain actually feels.
Well,
if you freak out,
it probably does that too,
right?
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
There's ways to do it.
I mean,
why Wildwood Indians,
native Americans,
when they would do those,
those battle cries.
Why else are they doing that?
But getting fired up.
Yeah.
You get hyped up by yelling or singing a song.
Viking.
Yeah.
Is that New Zealand,
New Zealand,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Well they uh,
they would play,
it's this video of them plan the USA team.
Oh yeah.
And they're doing this elaborate thing they're doing.
It's very elaborate.
And when just energetic and they cut to the USA team.
And that kind of looking back,
Kinda just con,
not confused,
but just what's going on.
And they went through this whole thing.
Is this right here?
Yeah,
it did.
In a basketball game.
He had a basketball volume.
This is ridiculous.
Basketball
and
dusted by 45 points.
Yeah.
You playing NBA superstars,
you fuck the dummies?
What is this?
What a cult is for the it means that's what they do all the time.
But it's just,
it seems so stupid.
Well,
it seems stupid if you have you played basketball,
this is stupid.
Something can have evolved as a virtue in some circumstances and still be of the
type that if magnified beyond its proper limits becomes pathological.
So let me tell you something I learned about Hitler,
which really I haven't recovered from my shock from this.
So we'd been looking at the relationship between political belief and
personality.
Okay?
And your political belief is strongly determined by your temperament.
So liberal left types are high in trait openness.
That's creativity and low in conscientiousness.
But you can fragment conscientiousness up into industriousness and orderliness.
And the real predictor for conservatism is an orderliness,
not industriousness.
And you might think,
well that's no surprise,
right wingers are more orderly,
hence Hitler's call for order,
let's say.
But it's one thing to s two to posit that.
And another thing to measure it,
now it's measurable and it appears that orderliness is associated with
sensitivity to discussed.
And this is actually a really big deal.
It's a really big deal.
So there's a paper that was published in plause one about three years ago
looking at the relationship between the prevalence of infectious diseases and
authoritarian political attitudes.
And they did it country by country and then within countries by state or
province.
And the correlation between the prevalence of infectious diseases and
authoritarian slash right wing political beliefs at the local individual level
was 0.6.
And so I want to take this apart a little bit.
Okay.
So the idea is that this is part of what you might describe as the extended
behavioral immune system.
And one of the problems with the interactions between groups of human beings in
our evolutionary past was,
well,
exactly what happened to the native Americans is,
you know,
they came out and shook hands with the Spanish can keystone doors,
and then within a couple of generations,
90% of them were dead of smallpox and measles and mumps.
And so it's been a truism in our evolutionary past that if you meet a group of
isolated,
if you're a group of isolated humans and you meet another group of isolated
humans and you trade pathogens,
there's a real possibility that you and everyone you know are going to be dead
in no time flat.
And so we have a disgust mechanism that that produces this implicit,
let's call it racial,
racial and ethnic bias.
That is part and parcel of the human cognitive landscape.
But the problem with that is that it's rooted in a disgust mechanism that
actually serves as a protective function.
Now,
when I was sorting this out,
I was reading Hitler's table talk and Hitler's table talk is a very interesting
book.
It's a book,
a book of his spontaneous mealtime utterances from 1939 to 1942 and I went
through with this new knowledge because people think of conservatives as if like
or fascist as afraid of those who are different.
They're not afraid,
they're disgusted.
And that's not the same thing because you burn things you're disgusted by.
And so it was terrifying to me to read it because then I also thought,
oh well disgust,
sensitivity is associated with orderliness and you need to order in a society in
order to maintain it.
And the Germans are very orderly and that was actually a canonical part of their
civilization.
And part of actually what makes them great and powerful.
And that just had to tilt a little farther than necessary and all of a sudden
everything needed to be get cleaned.
And you know,
Hitler talked about cleanliness all the time and he actually meant that.
And so this thing that's emerging,
you know,
you talked about its biological basis,
it's evolutionary basis.
It is,
it's part of this deeply rooted disgust system that protects us from dangerous
pathogens that can manifest itself in.
And does manifest itself in the political realm.
It's not good.
So.